what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so picking back up with Messiah
Complex again this is this is one of the
coolest stories when it comes to the
whole x-men concept cuz remember this is
the baby like this is this is this
little kid the first child born after
the events of house of M when the
Scarlet Witch took everybody's powers
away took like 98% of the mutant
populations powers away it's been a
whole mad race that's all this is this
is like a massive mad race to find this
kid on one side you got mr. sinister
this mutant geneticist you've got the
purifiers and then you've got the x-men
trying to find them but the other thing
that this dead is it saw the return of
cable that's what we talked about in the
last video the cables basically back and
the cable has this baby now this is a
very important thing because the future
of the of the mutant race hinges on this
kid that's how it's perceived what is
this baby capable of is it possible that
it's got some sort of a genome that can
either be used modified or what have you
that can just start bolstering people's
powers that's the big question people
have because remember in the x-men
landscape you've got mutants like leech
that has the ability to shut off
people's powers or what if this baby is
the opposite it has the ability to turn
powers on and so that's the question
that the x-men are asking that's what
they're trying to figure out here and so
of course within basically tracking down
different forces along the way the
purifiers the Marauders so on and so
forth they have for the most part been
pretty wrecked but making them return
back to the Xavier Institute the problem
they're facing here is the Xavier
Institute itself is under attack just
because of the fact that the human
pilots of these sentinels are now
basically just you know going awry and
attacking everyone now for those of you
guys who are catching up here finally
the events of House of M what you had is
you had something called the office of
national emergency oh one II and that
was basically I'm sorry ah Oh any and
that was basically like jump-started by
the federal government now the idea was
that the the sentinels were in the past
and Marvel Comics they've been
autonomous meaning that they don't
really have human pilots and instead
they function according to whatever
programming they have in this the humans
control the Sentinels like they're
literally pilots inside the Sentinels
moving them around but the pilots have
essentially been taken over by a kind of
nano virus ah that was exposed to them
by Cassandra Nova now Cassandra Nova is
someone that we haven't really talked
about before and if you're if you're new
to comics you probably don't really know
anything about her and she's very much a
foreign name to you Cassandra Nova was a
character created by Grant Morrison and
the idea was that he created her as it
means to show like you know negativity
and evil and so you know yadda yadda all
that Grant Morrison stuff inside of
comet
she's like a Magistrato I think is what
it is but the idea was originally she
was just like the unborn twin of Xavier
basically and he had like destroyed her
in the womb and the reason why was
because Xavier had realized how evil she
was she was going to be you know this
terrible thing it was a really weird
situation but the biggest claim to fame
to Cassandra Nova is that she had
basically reinstated these things called
wild sentinels which is to say sentinels
it literally existed in the wild they
were kind of created out there and had
whatever programming any one particular
person wanted to give them so long as
they were part of the Bolivar Trask gene
which is to say the genealogy of the man
who invented the Sentinels and so as a
result what ended up happening is she
basically sent these wild sentinels to
Genosha which was an island where
mutants could exist they could live
without concern about mutant oppressors
or anything like that and she had the
the Sentinels Massacre 16 million
mutants it was insane but she's always
been one of those characters who
depending on who's writing the story
sometimes she's kind of an ally of the
x-men more often than not she's an enemy
and so the result of this is that these
sentinels being taken over or I guess
these pilots being taken over by kind of
virus allows the Saturno but you go
through and literally start attacking
the x-men now there is a lot going on
with this and there is something bigger
happening behind the scenes and we'll
find out at the end of this video but
something else to also notice here is
that all the telepaths have basically
been knocked out and that was done for a
reason it was done explicitly so that
nobody would realize what it is is
actually going on here in response to
this you also have like like x-23 Laura
Kenney her forces showing back up at the
Xavier Institute
you've got the field group of the x-men
Wolverine and those guys who are who are
coming back from their mission and so
they're all kind of descending back on
to the Institute at the time that
everything is going awry so it's really
just kind of a gathering of the x-men to
you know eliminate these sentinels and
get rid of them now of course one of
them does show up and that's when you
basically learned they've been taken
over by this virus of sorts but of
course that versions basically defeated
and another one gets away and that's
really about it but following this
there's this really really cool
conversation that ends up happening
between Wolverine and Cyclops and this
is really really awesome because what
happens if sock hops basically sits down
and says okay the gloves need to come
off we've been trying to do this
peaceful coexistence thing and it's not
working for us we've got the purifiers
after us we've got the Marauders after
us we're literally being hit from every
side it's time to start playing hardball
again and the reason why this matters is
for a couple things the first is because
this begins or really starts to see this
sort of gradual decline of
Cyclops become you know becoming a
villain in the sense that he starts to
become more and more extreme and that's
one of the things that it really took
about ten years to make that happen the
the idea of Cyclops kind of becoming
more and more extreme almost becoming
magneto esque in terms of how we dealt
with various confrontations that took a
long time leading up to you know 2014
really 2012 when it really started to
pop off but the other reason why this
matters is because Cyclops says if we're
gonna go after a cable because he's the
one that has the kid this is cable that
we're talking about and that's one thing
to bear in mind there's a really cool
story called a Avengers X sanction where
cable takes on the Avengers and the
x-men and beats them all and so when
you're talking about someone like that
he's very very capable he's got
futuristic technology he's a master when
it comes to like military strategy he's
a master tactician he's a very very
capable guy and so it's not like you
just send Wolverine in to just pummel
cable and then take the baby and leave
like hey but we'll pull out every stop
in order to achieve whatever his goal
happens to be and that's when Cyclops
responds by saying we can't just send
anyone in to do this what we need is the
group like we need a strike force team
and that's when we end up seeing the
return of x-force now we'll probably do
a video explaining x-force once we get
closer to the release of Deadpool 2 but
the long and short of this is that
originally x-force was really the new
mutants like the new mutants were
introduced by by Marvel in a storyline
where it was believed the x-men had died
at the hands of the brood and so the new
mutants were kind of like the new
generation of mutants the original x-men
eventually came back and the new mutants
were kind of free-floating for a while
and then when Rob Liefeld took over the
new mutants line of comics uh he started
with issue number 86 introduced cable
and issue number 87 and from that issue
going forward to issue number 100 he
started in molding uh the new mutants
into an actual strike force team that
was led by cable hence the reason why
new mutants cancels issue number 100
x-force number one picks up and it's a
seamless transition and so with that
going forward like from that point going
into the future of Marvel comics because
x-force was so popular Marvel always
kept it the same it was always a strike
force team but of course what is up
happening here is you basically end up
having cable who comes across the forces
of Lady Deathstrike not too big just
kind of a small little thing some stuff
happens whatever you know any basically
manages a hold his own against him as we
would expect I mean it's Lady
Deathstrike she's got you know some
really sharp fingers and you know she's
really good at fighting but there's
really nothing that's special about her
one thing to focus though and this is
kind of a kind of a
thing at least at this point in the
story is kind of a background thing the
whole idea of Jamie madrix and Lela
Miller remember when it came to them
working alongside this they were
basically sent to forge basically this
this mutant this like Tony Stark but the
the knowledge he possesses is a
byproduct of the power that he has his
ability to reverse-engineer technology
to know how things work that's his
actual mutant power the idea is that he
basically created a kind of
interdimensional time to time machine
that would give Layla Miller and Jaime
madrix multiple man the ability to jump
into like two different alternate
universes to find out why everybody's
seeking after this baby what it is this
going on here and so they ended up
jumping into another into a different
reality eighty years in the future and
is basically like Days of Future past is
really what it is
oh there's mutant concentration camps
you know mutants are basically thrown
into these camps we don't know what it
was the catalysts that led to this
universe being the way it is but the
fact that it's here and the the very
nature of their actions indicates that
it has something to do with this baby
and now we actually know what's going on
but for the sake of like you know
remaining in the moment I don't want to
spoil it at all because it is kind of
cool but the other part of this is that
you basically end up picking up with
Wolverine and his forces are basically
x-force intercepting cable in his fight
with Lady Deathstrike now this is pretty
awesome because for the most part I mean
like like x-23 in these guys they're
able to face off against these forces
and that's why this isn't like a major
thing the big takeaway from this and
this is one reasons why I love cable so
much is Wolverine about among everyone
here Wolverines the only one who really
knows the threat that cable poses
because Wolverines been there ever since
cable first popped up and that's why
this entire time he's basically been
telling x-force do not underestimate
cable now of course
Wolverine him these guys locating
locating whoa ver I'm sorry locating out
cable that's because of the fact that
like the Stepford cuckoos and everybody
basically recovered and and they use you
know of course cerebro to locate where
it is the cable was that but again the
cool thing about this is that what cable
ends up doing is basically doubling back
and that's one of the funny things about
this is because in any normal
circumstance Wolverine would have
realized what was going on right like he
would have been chasing cable down and
would have said well I've already been
here before but being so caught up in
the moment chasing after cable x-force
and and Wolverine dealing with the
forces of Lady Deathstrike it's enough
to throw anybody off regardless of how
honed their skills are and so when
Wolverine ends up doubling back he
finally realizes what's going on ask the
question as to why and we find out the
cable actually Jack the black bird of
Wolverine
he literally hijacked the ship and took
off and it's so cool and it's such a
smart thing to do is it's really one of
the more interesting things about his
character but that's the whole nature
behind this that's the important thing
to walk away from with this it's just
how capable cable is and just how
dangerous he truly can be and so what we
end up doing is fast-forwarding and
picking up with cable when he shows up
in Dallas Texas heading to a Eagle Plaza
and the reason why is because this is
where Forge is located now cable showing
up here is basically saying look I've
got this maybe I need to be able to time
travel I need your time travel device
now this would by cable time what would
end up happening most likely is cable
would basically jump forward to his own
time law is on timeline and then
reassemble a new time travel device and
that would give him the ability to start
jumping around again but showing up here
what he ends up finding out is that
forge has basically been taken out and
that's the mystery is who wants it that
took out forge and so what we end up
doing is picking up with cable being
knocked out and we end up finding out
the person who orchestrated all this is
actually bishop that Bishop was the one
who incapacitated the the telepaths
Bishop was the one who set the virus
free on the sentinels as a distraction
to keep the x-men preoccupied so they
wouldn't realize what it was that he was
doing Bishop is the one who traveled to
forge his house and Bishop is the one
who shot him and that's the question why
is Bishop doing all of this but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
too comments explained make sure you
guys have the sub button to become part
of the robb cork you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]